mit dem Begriff Tele Shopping kann ja
sicherlich jeder von euch was anfangen
Fernsehsender wie QVC machen mit
Verkäufen wir Livestreaming richtig
Kohle für mich ist das schon sehr
verblüffend das funktioniert aber es
funktioniert ja irgendwie wenn es also
schon im TV funktioniert sollte es ja
auch auf Social Media funktionieren ich
hatte bei mir zu Hause noch so viele
alte Sachen rumfliegen und dachte mir
wir machen ein Experiment und testen das
ganze mal aus kann man also mit Live
Shopping auf Social Media reich werden
und damit hey Leute was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen Video
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es allen
gut ihr habt schon gehört wir befassen
uns im heutigen Video mal mit dem Thema
live Shopping da habe ich schon gerade
erwähnt live Shopping ist jetzt nichts
Revolutionäres das gibt's schon seit
Jahrzehnten aber noch nicht auf Social
Media für die Leute die mit dem Begriff
live Shopping nicht so viel anfangen
können ich erkläre mal ganz kurz also
eigentlich ist es ja selbst erklärend
aber ich erkläre es trotzdem mal was ist
eigentlich die Definition von Leid gibt
es dann eine Definition zu hä live
Shopping ist eine Bezeichnung eines aus
den USA stammenden Trends im Bereich des
elektronischen Handels für einen sehr
kurzzeitiges Sonderangebot eines
einzelnen Produktes die einzelnen
Produkte temporär zu einem reduzierten
Preis angeboten werden wird bei den
Käufern der Impuls versteckt schnell
zugreifen zu müssen ja besser hätte ich
so nicht zusammenfassen können kurz
vorweg noch für euch ich habe hier ganz
viel Ware also das muss einfach mal weg
ja und ich habe einfach keine Zeit den
ganzen Bums bei Ebay reinzustellen oder
sonst was deswegen ist mein Plan ich
will mich auch an live Shopping
versuchen und das an euch rauszuhauen zu
wirklich günstigen Preisen über
Instagram und ich hoffe dass ich das
kann ich habe keine Ahnung ich habe es
noch nie gemacht wir haben schon einige
Leute dazu geraten dass ich das
unbedingt mal ausprobieren muss und ja
deswegen sitze ich heute hier und wir
testen mal ob ich mit Live Shopping viel
Geld verdienen könnte ich war für das
ganze Projekt letzte Woche in Berlin
beim Daniel was geht schöne Grüße ich
bin nämlich absolute Anfänger habe davon
keine Ahnung und ich wollte mir erstmal
ein paar Tipps holen und Daniel macht es
schon ein bisschen länger und wir fahren
jetzt erstmal nach Berlin also ich warte
halt schon aber ihr tut jetzt einfach
mal so als würde jetzt nach Berlin
fahren zu Daniel mit mir und dann gucken
wir mal was wir da so gerockt haben im
Live Shopping also ab Nachbarn City für
mich ging es also mal wieder nach Berlin
zum Daniel ich war dort letztens schon
mal für ein Video vielleicht könnt ihr
euch daran noch erinnern auf jeden Fall
hat Daniel Karotten riesenlager dort
werden jeden Monat hunderte Paletten
verwertet von Retouren A bis Z alles
möglich ist dabei und er macht seit
einiger Zeit auch wöchentlich live
Shopping Events also genau der richtige
Mann für meinen Experiment so Leute was
geht ähm komme Euch rein ich bin jetzt
hier beim Daniel na ich habe ein
bisschen Schicht da alles fit du ich bin
gespannt weil Daniel hat mir gesagt live
Shopping ist jetzt das neue Ding ich
muss mal vorbeikommen er zeigt mir das
du hast jetzt bei Instagram gleich
und das ist wirklich das neue Gold also
wirklich so krass wie du da aktuell
verkaufen kannst das macht so Spaß das
Wahnsinn also ich kann es mir ja fast
nicht vorstellen dass es zu krass abgeht
aber ich bin gespannt weil der Plan
dieses Videos ist es ja dann dass ich
das auch mal teste mal gucken wie ich
das so kann interessant wenn du das
gemacht ja also Leute deswegen bin ich
in erster Linie hier und das ist dann so
was verkaufst du da alles aber ich
verkaufe da manchmal wirklich iPhones
Apple watches also direkt Paletten
Mystery Boxen wirklich alles was man
sich vorstellen kann alles andere tun
Restposten echt wild und die Leute sind
verrückt danach okay ich bin gespannt ja
das sind Paletten
für dich im Live Shopping verkaufen also
ich soll im Live Shopping auch mit oder
ich ich versuche mich mal ein bisschen
hier so Freestyle aber ich habe halt bei
mir zu Hause auch noch ganz viele Sachen
im Büro rumfliegen ich weiß nicht was
ich damit machen soll und ich komme
irgendwie nicht dazu die zu verkaufen
das sind Retouren an Elektronik Alter
geil das wollten schon die ganze Zeit
die Zuschauer von mir haben jetzt habe
ich endlich die Palette und mal sehen
wie die die kaufen werden auf jeden Fall
deutlich voller aus als beim letzten Mal
jetzt hier war
auch noch viel voller bis vor paar Tagen
gewesen hier ist unsere Freunde also
Leute da hinter mir ist jetzt deren live
Shopping Setup Bruder von Daniel der
tippt das dann direkt immer einen Laptop
wenn jemand was kaufen möchte jetzt
gleich geht's da los ich bin echt mal
gespannt ob ich das auch kann heute
geht's wieder los es gibt wieder ein
schönes live für euch geil dass sie
wieder alle eingeschaltet habt so wen
sehen wir denn alles hier wieder im Chat
der Tobi Mike Didi linda hat alle wieder
fleißig heute am Start 030 der darf
natürlich nicht fehlen Jenny Raffa sind
immer die typischen Leute die hier sind
freut mich teilweise wieder dabei seid
grüß Dich
da gucke ich immer dann was die Leute so
schreiben und ich habe ihn so bisschen
als Verstärkung genommen er will auch
sich das Live Shopping angucken würde es
vielleicht auch mal ausprobieren die
beste kannst du auch ausziehen aber
dieses steht dir auf jeden Fall ihr
müsst wissen das ist ja immer so 20
Leute schreiben dann 5 €, ich gucke aber
wer als erstes mit seinem Namen bei mir
hier oben steht den Namen nenne ich dann
hier überweist dann 5 € ihr müsst uns
auch eine Adresse schreiben es gibt
einmalig 5 € Versand das heißt ihr könnt
so viel kaufen wie ihr wollt und scheint
nur einmalig 5 € Versand darf ich ganz
kurz in der Zwischenfrage stellen und
wenn dann jemand den Zuschlag bekommt
der kriegt dann der kriegt von meinem
Bruder eine Nachricht ja mein Bruder
schreibt der Person aber Instagram bei
Instagram
er schreibt sofort ja und da ist dann
unsere PayPal Daten und unsere
Überweisungsdaten okay und er muss alles
klar okay die Regeln lauten
folgendermaßen es wird ein Produkt in
die Kamera gezeigt und ein Preis
aufgerufen beispielsweise 20 € der oder
die Zuschauerin die dann als erstes 20 €
in den kommentiert bekommt den Zuschlag
eine einmalige Versandgebühr von 5 Euro
fällt für jeden Käufer an damit kann man
aber so viel kaufen wie man möchte und
zahlt halt für alles am Ende zusammen
nur 5 € Versandgebühr klingt gut und wir
schreiben dann offenen Zettel den Namen
vom insta kleben auf dem Produkt und
dann können wir es auch zuordnen und
dann am nächsten Tag versenden okay so
holen wir den Tisch hier nach vorne dann
kann ich euch das auch immer bisschen
besser zeigen Bügeleisen das ist ne also
Bügeleisen dieses Modell mein Bruder
kann auch mal schnell nachgucken ich
würde sagen kostet 130 € so meine
Einschätzung der sieht vom optischen
ziemlich gut aus kann mir glaube ich
Alex noch bestätigen
damit kann man einiges wegbügeln Leute
da hat er vollkommen recht ich teste in
der Zeit einfach das flügeleisen genau
ich muss kurz einmal in den Flugmodus
gehen Leute geht jetzt nicht alle raus
einmal Flugmodus kurz
gesehen das kostet normalerweise 149 €
ihr könnt jetzt und hier kaufen für
gerade einmal 45 € wer als erstes 45 €
für diese Dampfbügelstation rein
schreibt der kriegt sie ich bin gespannt
wer der erste ist mit 45 Euro wir gucken
mal und System otto war der erste System
otto hat 45 als erstes geschrieben
[Musik]
also sehr gebraucht Leute für diese
Maschine die ihr hier seht von
KitchenAid nehme ich jetzt 14 €, also 20
€ 12
und das verkauft an Stefan 84
[Musik]
es ist das XR mit 64 GB ich werde euch
jetzt wieder einen Preis nehmen
gehandelt werden die im Netz könnt ihr
gucken zwischen 250 bis 320 Euro je nach
Zustand ja
sozusagen ihr könnt es heute hier bei
mir kaufen für gerade einmal 210 Euro
also wir spart mindestens wie viel Euro
an die spart man mindestens 50 bis 100 €
die beiden haben gerade gekämpft und die
Angie war auf jeden Fall kein schlechter
Preis Andy da hast du alles richtig
gemacht
s32
am704 ur so schlecht 299 bei Saturn 299
bei Saturn
[Musik]
und euch dann noch einen wunderschönen
Abend ja es war wieder Wahnsinn gewesen
macht's gut tschüss ja witzig war das
erfolgreiche das war schon gut gewesen
so ist eigentlich immer so krass gewesen
in zwei Stunden haben wir jetzt einen
Umsatz gemacht von meinem Bruder kann ja
mal nach 4000 € ungefähr 4000 4000 €
Umsatz in zwei Stunden ist schon schon
gut kann man nicht mehr können ne also
lohnt sich auf jeden Fall dass man hier
so die Miete und alles andere bezahlen
kann sagen wir so ich sage euch dann
einfach was ich bei mir dann wenn ich
das teste oder so genau ne okay ja nice
nice nice Leute was geht ab heute ist
der große Tag wir haben heute Freitag
ich habe das ganze noch mal jetzt von
heute Abend auf nachmittags verlegt weil
ich dachte mir irgendwie das ist
vielleicht schlauer eine Freundin von
mir kommt gleich vorbei die Johanna die
war auch schon mal in dem ein oder ein
Video und die sitzt dann hier ich habe
es mir einfach so abgeguckt wie Daniel
das mache ich mache das jetzt einfach
also Daniel schöne Grüße und vielen
vielen Dank nochmal checkt auf jeden
Fall unbedingt mal sein insta auch aus
hier blende ich euch allen wir haben
hier zum Beispiel einen MacBook eine
Zitruspresse wir haben hier Uhren Schuhe
irgendwelche Klamotten die sind gar
nicht mal günstig einen professional ghd
advanced Styler eine Kamera nerfs wir
haben Objektiv das kostet neue irgendwie
900 € und dann haben wir hier noch eine
Playstation 4 wir haben Fernseher wir
haben einen Koffer mit Inhalt und ja ich
freue mich richtig ich glaube das wird
geil ich muss auch sagen mein Ziel ist
es nicht jetzt für Geld verdienen es
soll einfach alles weg weil ich brauche
hier Platz aber ich denke wir sollten so
irgendwas zwischen 1000 und 2000 €
machen alles über 1000 €. okay das
reicht mir okay Leute meine Assistentin
Johanna ich weiß ich Filme jetzt nicht
deine Haare die hat sich extra beeilt
die haben aber noch eine Liste erstellt
mit den ganzen Sachen da kannst du dann
den Preis eintragen und in Instagram
Namen ey Leute ich bin wirklich ein
bisschen nervös früher waren Livestreams
gar kein Ding für mich habe es einfach
mal easy durchgezogen aber ich habe
schon ewig nicht mehr gemacht hier steht
jetzt der Stream ja alles sehr
unprofessionell ich weiß wir ziehen das
jetzt einfach easy entspannt durch sein
Kinderspiel ich bin ja schon ewig
Youtuber hi leute was geht ab ich hoffe
euch geht's gut
ich habe es schon so lange nicht mehr
gemacht ey ohne Witz ich bin ein
bisschen nervös ich war schon ewig nicht
mehr so direkt auf diesem Instagram
Account live aber jetzt bin ich mal
wieder ich habe ja schon angekündigt was
wir so machen werden heute mach noch
kurz ein paar Gymnastikübungen zum
aufwärmen und dann geht das schon das
wichtig damit man halt ne sich den
Körper vorher ein bisschen so ja ja
dann starten wir doch direkt hier mit
den nerfs Hauptsache gehen weg und wie
gesagt die dies als erstes kommentieren
wir haben hier einmal die nerve
Shockwave RD 15 ich glaube die kostet 35
dann haben wir hier noch eine Turbo CS
18 und noch dieses Ding ist halt eher
für Kinder ne und die würde ich jetzt
alle zusammen kommen sagen wir mal 28 €
die dir als erstes jetzt 28 € schreiben
kriegen den Zuschlag wir schauen mal
rein Kimberly alles Gute du hast es für
28 gekauft was ist denn hier mit meinem
scheiß drecks Handy wieder los Leute ach
das hängt guck mal hier kommen einfach
keine Kommentare an ich hasse dieses
Ding Johanna dann zähle ich auf dich du
sagst es immer okay also Kimberly du
hast auf jeden Fall die drei nerfs hier
für 28 € legen wir zur Seite und ja ich
schreibe dir dann gleich dann kriegst du
das Montag zugeschickt so wir haben hier
eine Playstation 4 Slim ist das glaube
ich mit 500 GB und shoulder noch dazu
wer jetzt als erstes hier oder wer
interessiert ist an der PS4 und als
erstes in die Kommentare 95 € schreibt
bekommt die Playstation 4 95 € für eine
PS4 also das ist ja wohl so Leute wie
man hier sehen kann ich habe dann
fleißig weiterverkauft wir hatten
wirklich echt viel dabei und ja einfach
aber das Produkt in die Kamera gehalten
euch gezeigt und es ging wirklich echt
schnell also ich habe einfach einen
Preis gesagt es war schon immer ein
guter Preis aber es waren immer direkt
567 Leute dabei die direkt Bock hatten
auf das Produkt und ja es ging alles
richtig schnell weg also wir hatten halt
MacBooks wir hatten hier den Fernseher
z.B ähm irgendwelche Klamotten Schuhe
ich habe solche eben schon gezeigt an
die Leute die gerade das Youtube Video
schauen hier sind jetzt die ganzen Leute
im Chat haben gerade Schuhe gekauft es
ist so witzig ey bis gleich ich mache
jetzt noch den Stream zu Ende macht aber
echt Spaß und ja hat mir echt unfassbar
viel Spaß gemacht ich war auch
überrascht dass so viele teilgenommen
haben und so viele Bock drauf hatten
deswegen das wird in Zukunft bestimmt
noch mal geben ich schaue mich da mal
ein bisschen um und ja wir haben am Ende
glaube ich ein ziemlich gutes Ergebnis
erzielt das seht ihr jetzt
so Leute Stream ist vorbei hat ultra
Spaß gemacht das ging echt schnell also
ich habe jetzt wie lange eine
Dreiviertelstunde in einer
Dreiviertelstunde haben wir über 20
Sachen verkauft also ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass es so gut funktioniert ich
bin alles ganz schnell los geworden klar
die Preise waren heute auch phänomenal
aber hier stehen jetzt alle Leute in der
Tabelle Johanna rechnen das ganze jetzt
mal zusammen ich bin echt gespannt ich
würde mal schätzen 15 haben wir gemacht
nur wir sind schon über 1000
wie viel
super ey perfekt ich habe ja gesagt
alles über 1000 ist gut und es hat auch
gut funktioniert Experiment geglückt
oder also das war echt wie von
Zauberhand live Shopping ist schon ein
Ding ne Leute ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen das war's eigentlich schon mit
dem Video Fazit ist folgt mir gerne auf
Instagram ich werde schauen dass ich in
Zukunft coole Ware bekomme und hin und
wieder mal Livestream Shopping machen
kann Alex wie heiße ich da eigentlich
habe ich auch für das ganze Experiment
extra 9 Instagram Account erstellt und
zwar diesen hier Alex wie Shopping ich
wollte doch da eigentlich den Livestream
machen habe mich dann aber doch dazu
entschieden dass erstmal auf meinem
Haupt Instagram Account zu machen wenn
ich das noch mal mache ich weiß nicht
genau auf welche ich dann live gehe aber
folgt auch sehr gerne beiden Instagram
Accounts da würde ich mich sehr freuen
also Alex wie und Alex wie Shopping
schadet nicht abonniert den Kanal danke
auch an Daniel checkt gerne mal bei
Daniel vorbei und wir sehen uns nächsten
Sonntag wieder gibt's neues cooles Video
haut rein Leute ciao